i think levy came up with it
or chat came up with it i don't know who
came it was brilliant though
okay let's play e6 again let's play
normal chess after that game in bangko
i've lost faith in that opening
let's play uh okay
nine g2 okay i'll play rook e8 put
bishop on f8
the idea is to play e5 i think if i'm
not wrong
they can also play c5
um what should it do
i'll play c5 if you play d5 it's good
he does not i'll take back
[Music]
it's too symmetrical for my liking
i want to complicate i i know that d6 is
not a good move
but i want to complicate
let's play rook b8 b6 bishop b7
kind of moose
exchange this bishop if i can
yeah i heard actually that that day levy
was making a lot of impressions
i like this if i can exchange this
bishop already it's a good thing
it's good stuff
have you ever sent a challenge i'll try
to accept and play as much as i can
can't promise but i'll try okay let's
take this bishop
for once queen c7 attacked the weak pawn
oh 93 oh this was his idea smart i play
e6 stop in in i'd be five business
put rook on c8
queen b7
[Music]
oh i can play g6 bishop at six
f4 okay that's not a good move
i mean that doesn't look like a good
move i'll play rook c7 rook c8 b5
maybe i can exchange okay let's exchange
queens
rook c8
in my childhood i used to love playing
endgames
even now i like it from time to time h5
my ideas to play knight g4
oh he missed it nice i take out his main
defender
and now c4 pawn is hanging very clean
very clean
doesn't matter your rating guys you can
just send a challenge i'll play against
everyone there's no rating limit as such
yeah he had to give up on and he gave it
this way
[Music]
let's just take rook b7
a4 i can play rk8 i attacked the spawn
on a4
probably play okay he was back then i
have knight b6 knight c4
good stuff
my only bishop on f8 is not playing in
wait what
f5 can i just play knight f4
oh 94 knight c3 that's the trick got it
so i'll play ef5 first and then take on
a4
yeah he missed it probably wait what
am i missing something knight takes a4
the knight on b5 bishop on b2 everything
is hanging
now i don't see it i see a pawn and i
take it
yeah just negative for you free pawns
are like uh
treats for me
10 hearts at the max now oh
[Music]
okay that was good